pernod benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire bonsoir
arnaud benedetti d'être avec nous on
vient de le voir ont souhaité beaucoup
en tout cas souhaité une union sacrée
avec cette gestion de la crise du corona
virus est effectivement des polémiques
l'union sacrée qui se fissure est ce que
c'était souhaitable ça fait désordre en
tout cas je ne sais pas c'était
souhaitable mais vous savez la vie
politique est ce qu'elle est et
qu'inévitablement compte tenu d'un
contexte qui est extrêmement tendue il y
à des dissensions qui apparaissent sur
la question des municipal c'est
absolument évident dans la mesure où on
a vu que la gestion de ce dossier a
donné lieu pour le moins un retard à
l'allumage de la part de l'exécutif il
est clair que si l'exécutif lorsqu'il a
rencontré à matignon il ya maintenant
plus de 15 jours l'ensemble des forces
politiques avaient mis sur la table la
question de ce report éventuel des
élections municipales peut-être
aurait-il obtenu un consensus politique
pour que en effet les élections soient
reportées va se poser ensuite un
deuxième problème c'est que qu'on le
veuille ou non le premier tour de ces
élections municipales à vue quand même
sa sincérité profondément altérée par la
déclaration du premier ministre qui
constitue un acte de gouvernement
le samedi soir à 20 heures avec
notamment la décision de fermer
l'ensemble des commerces des cafés et
des restaurants et on peut considérer
que medec mécaniquement cette décision a
entraîné une baisse massive de la
participation
se pose ensuite la question en effet du
maintien de la conservation des
résultats pour les communes c'est-à-dire
les 5000 communes qui n'ont pas élu pour
l'instant de conseil municipal
il y à la redoutent qu'un vrai avec
nouvelles questions sur le plan à la
fois juridique et bien évidemment
constitutionnel en tout cas la question
ne se pose pas pour les 30000 maire élu
au premier tour qui peuvent considérer
leur élection comme un cul est acquise a
assuré
ministre de l'intérieur quel est votre
regard d'expert sur cette question il ya
une partie de la question qui n'est pas
réglé une autre qu'il est enfin c'est
vrai que ça manque de cohérence tous à
nos lecteurs il ya deux problèmes
d'abord c'est maire et ses conseillers
municipaux auront été mal élu mal élu
parce que la participation a été faible
et on sait qu'en règle générale
l'élection municipale est une des
élections avec l'élection présidentielle
qui est la plus plébiscitée en termes de
participation par nos compatriotes
oui ils ont été bâle élu parce que la
participation a été extrêmement
extrêmement faible c'est le record
historique en tout cas d'abstention lors
d'une élection municipale et que se pose
encore une fois la question de
l'altération du scrutin du fait tout
simplement de cette mobilisation
électorale qui a été faible donc la
bonne logique voudrait que finalement le
premier tour de ces élections soit
purement et simplement annulée se pose
le problème ensuite de la question de
l'organisation du deuxième tour 6 mois
ou en tout cas deux mois ou trois mois
après c'est à dire on parle pour
l'instant de la date du 21 juin
or vous savez qu'une élection pour
qu'elle se déroule dans des conditions
qui soient sincères doivent et une doit
doit en tout cas s'intégrer dans une
séquence temporelle qui soit
suffisamment en tout cas serrée pour que
là aussi les conditions de l'exercice
électoral soit considéré comme sincère
et non altéré par des aléas qui
viendraient quelque part fausser les
règles du jeu pour paris selon vous est
ce qu agnès buzyn est véritablement
mesure de poursuivre sa campagne on sait
qu'elle a fait couler beaucoup d'encre
mais hier je vous rappel pour les
téléspectateurs qui n'auraient pas suivi
l'ex ministre de la santé qui a affirmé
qu'elle savait que l'élection ne se
tiendraient pas en tout cas qui avait
des risques ainsi l'épidémie s'aggraver
est là
d'ailleurs inverti sur la gravité de
cette épidémie
aujourd'hui airbus à un concours pour
paris est ce que c'est tenable pour est
là ça me paraît difficilement tonale
auto nabeul regard des déclarations
qu'elle vient de faire dans le journal
le monde si vous voulez on a le
sentiment qu'il s'agit d'une d'une
candidate qui aujourd'hui n'est plus en
mesure à la fois psychologiquement et
politiquement de mener ce combat à à
paris les déclarations de madame bizarre
on en cause et c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire l'effet d'une bombe sur la
scène politique pour de multiples
raisons d'abord en tant que ou en tant
qu ancien ministre manifestement soit
elle était au courant de la gravité de
la situation peut se poser des questions
concernant son attitude au sein du
gouvernement les raisons pour lesquelles
finalement elle n'a pas alerté l'opinion
publique sur cette gravité de la
situation souvenez vous un ancien
ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement disait avec justesse
ministre ça ferme sa gueule ou ça
démissionne en l'occurrence madame buses
assez tu as très peu agi durant le
démarrage de la crise et ac décidé de
s'exprimer après le premier tour des
élections municipales d'encours dallas
on est là face à une attitude qui est
assez assez incohérente qui à mon sens
aujourd'hui délégitime complètement sa
candidature et sa tête sa candidature à
la mairie de paris donc en effet va se
poser un problème pour la république en
marge de trouvait vraisemblablement une
candidature de substitution à nouveau en
tête de liste à paris
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti d'avoir
été avec nous avoir apporté votre
analyse et